معنا الصحفي اشرف ابو عمره من مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح اهلا بك معنا
الف لا باس عليكم بطبيعه الحال كنت معنا
قبل دقائق في النشره السابقه لتغطيه
الاوضاع ما الذي حدث بعد
ذلك نعم تحياتي لك زميلي عبد السلام صراحه
وباعوه بالغه نجونا من الغاره الاسرائيليه
وكانت تبعد فقط امتار قليله جدا عن
تواجدنا بعد انتهاء من البث المباشر معكم
في اله السابقه وتفاجئنا بان طائرات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اغارت على بنايه خلف
المستشفى مباشره اي تبعد فقط عن قسم
الاستقبال والطوارء امتار قليله هذه
الغاره كانت بثلاثه صواريخ متتاليه عباره
عن غاره قويه جدا وعنيفه جدا هذه البنايه
هي بنايه سكنيه يتردد عليها المواطنين
النازحين في المنطقه الخلفيه للمستشفى
بداخلها بعض البقاله والسوبر ماركت
بالاضافه الى ال ذلك مقابل البنايه مباشره
هناك خيام النازحين الذين يجلسون بداخل
ساحه الساحه الخلفيه لمستشفى شهداء الاقصى
في دير البلح اعداد كبيره من المصابين
استطيع ان اقول لك الان بان قسم الاستقبال
والطوارئ بمستشفى شهداء الاقصى مليء تماما
بالجرحى وحتى الطاقم الطبي المتواجد الان
لا يستطيع السيطره على هؤلاء المصابين
والاعداد من الاصابات التي وصلت وتم حملها
على الايدي من المواطنين وال مار الذين
كانوا في الشارع ايضا هناك اعداد اخرى ما
زالت تحت انقاض البنايه التي تم تدميرها
على الباب الخلفي لمستشفى شهداء الاقصى في
دير البلح هنا حتى هذه اللحظات وبحسب
الطاقم الطبي المتواجد في المستشفى
كحصن من 10 شهداء تم اخراجهم من تحت انقاذ
البنايه ومن الساحه الفيه لمستشفى شهداء
الاقصا وما يقارب من 50 جريح حتى هذه
اللحظات جل الجرحى هم من النازحين من
المدنيين من ايضا الطواقم الطبيه سقي
سيارات الاسعاف الذين هم دائما يكونوا
متواجدين خلف المستشفى حتى اذا ما حدثت اي
عمليه قصف يخرجون مباشره من الناحيه
الغربيه للمستشفى حقيقه الوضع ماساوي جدا
في محيط المستشفى عشرات الجرحى المواطنين
حاله من الرعب والهلع دبت في صفوف الناس
هنا الذين كانوا يجلسون في خيامهم امنين
وبشكل مت مفاجاه بشكل مفاجئ قصفت هذه
الطائرات وبدون سابقه ظر وبثلاث صواريخ
عنيفه جدا حتى المستشفى نفسه الذي ك التي
كنا الذي كنا بداخله تعرض ايضا لاضرار
كبيره وجسمه عاد عن التحطم ل الزجاج
والنوافذ وعدد كبير من الاجهزه حتى في قسم
الاستقبال والطوارئ سقطت على الارض
والطاقم الطبي الان يحاول يعني محاوله
السيطره على عدد وكميات المصابين التي تم
نقلها من المكان باتجاه قسم الاستقبال
والطوارئ الغاره لم تكن بعيده وكانت فقط
على بعد امتار قليله من قسم الاستقبال
والطوارئ وا امتار قليله عن تواجد الطاقم
الصحفي الذي هو يغطي في المحافظه الوسطى
هنا ونحن كنا احد هؤلاء
الزملاء حصل ذلك دون سابق انذار هذه اليه
اسرائليه معتمده في الفتره الاخيره رغم
قرب المكان من مستشفى يفترض انه محمي
بالاعتبارات الدوليه دون سابق انذار حصل
ما حصل اشرف نعم زميل عبد السلام حقيقه
نحن كنا معكم على الهواء مباشره في
الرساله السابقه وكنا نتحدث عن اجمال
التطورات في المحافظه الوسطى تفاجانا من
قوه الصواريخ التي نزلت على الساحه
الخلفيه للمستشفى وعلى باب المستشفى كانت
صواريخ عنيفه بدون سابق انذار لم يكن اي
تطور ميداني هنا في هذه المنطقه الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه دخلت الاجواء مباشره
قامت بالاغ على هذه البنايه السكنيه
المكونه من ثلاثه طوابق س ها بالارض هناك
شاهدنا شضايا الصواريخ وهي تتنافر في كل
مكان الساحه الخلفيه للمستشفى المستشفى
نفسه ايضا قد تضرر ونحن شاهدنا عدد كبير
من الاقسام قد تضررت بشكل كبير اعداد
المصابين الهلع والرعب الذي كان سائدا هنا
في المنطقه ولكن نتحدث هنا عن المواطنين
الذين هم يجلسون في خيامهم نتحدث عن خيام
بسيطه بدائيه يجلسون عائلات كامله كانوا
هم قد نزحوا وطلبهم الجيش الاسرائيلي في
بيانات له بشكل رسمي بالتوجه الى مدينه
دير البلح وبالتحديد على الاماكن المعروفه
هنا وهذا المكان هنا اشير زميل عبد السلام
بانه من الاماكن المعروفه في دير البلح
بانه ياوي الاف النازحين الفلسطينيين
الذين جاؤوا سواء من مدينه غزه ومن شمال
القطاع ومؤخرا من مخيم البريج ومخيم
المغازي ومنطقه الزوايده اي مكان معروف
لدى الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وللجيش
الاسرائيلي بانه مكان ياوي نازحين عائلات
مدنيه اطفال نساء شاهدنا كل الاعمار
و الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ الذين هم
استشهدوا واصيبوا جراء هذه الغاره القويه
والعنيفه جدا حقيقه على بوابه مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى الخلفي ام تحدثت عن حاله
الرعب ونحن نتابع هذه الصور و وعدد من
المدنيين النساء والاطفال بعضهم مصاب ايضا
هذه المنطقه لم تعد امنه بالنسبه لهؤلاء
الذين كانوا يهتمون
بها نعم هي لم تعد امنه منذ تقريبا
الثلاثه ايام منذ 72 ساعه وطائرات الكوات
كابتر ايضا وهي الطائرات المصيره
الاسرائيليه باتت في الاونه الاخيره
يستخدمها الجيش الاسرائيلي بشكل كبير جدا
وخاصه هنا في محيط مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
استطيع ان اقول لك بان طائرات الكواد
كابتر خلال الساعات الماضيه والايام
الماضيه ايضا اطلقت النار بشكل عشوائي
وبشكل كثف في الشوارع الم المحيطه بمستشفى
شهداء الاقصى هذا الامر ايضا ادى الى وقوع
اصابات وهناك ايضا في المناطق الشرقيه
لمستشفى شهداء الاقصى بالقرب من مدرسه
المنفلوطي الطائرات المسيره الكوات كابتر
اطلقت النار ايضا على عدد من النازحين
هناك وهذا الامر ادى الى ارتقاء شهداء في
هذا هذا العمل عمل اطلاق النار بتجاه
المواطنين المواطنين ينجحون من هذه
المنطقه باتجاه رفح خلال الايام الماضيه
ولكن انا باعتقادي بعد هذه الغاره لم يبقى
احد في هذا المكان لانه ايه بصراحه تامه
المكان بات خطيرا تماما شكرا سنقف دائما
في المتابعه صحفي اشرف ابو عمره من مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح شكرا جزيلا